[Music]
happy vlogmas so right now it is 754
a.m. December 1st welcome to vlogmas
this is not a promise that I am going to
be vlogging everyday but this is a
promise that I will try my almost best
to post a video almost every day in
December blogging every day but trying
to make high quality videos it's not an
easy task so I am not planning on
killing myself to try to get you guys a
video every day while trying to live my
life but what I will be doing is I've
already filmed a bunch of really fun
Christmas videos some really fun collabs
and today will really spawned my vlogmas
video is because of this it's the Star
Wars advent calendar so my friend Rowell
gave me this present I swear to you
probably like I it feels like two months
ago and she's like you gotta open this
on December 1st so basically I've had a
my calendar December first open Rose
present bb-8 is freaking sledding down a
snowbank and this is now is being pumped
by a stormtrooper on like a snow blower
like this just everything about this box
it's just perfect
oh boy I also got all my Star Wars
pajama pants that my mom got me like
last year for Christmas man
Star Wars I'm so hyped for the new movie
like I absolutely cannot wait I also
just want to apologize because I'm kind
of still sleeping I haven't really slept
much this month at all well last Monday
cuz it's December but it's whatever I'm
doing I don't know welcome to my channel
let's open this up oh my gosh I'm so
pumped under some problems oh shoot I
did it wrong I just opened up the whole
entire thing and I'm not supposed to
doing that I gotta close this back up
you guys have this and this is a spoiler
stop watching now and skip to a few
minutes later technically it's not
really a spoiler because a whole of what
is on here is inside of here
there's your little face I'm so hyped
for Christmas the Holly Jolly Christmas
it's some of the do a lot of resin
anything
here he is all set up we're gonna put
him I don't know put him by the present
we'll set this up over here in my
kitchen office wait a minute I am so
confused right now because after further
inspection of this sect clearly these
numbers are out of order and you would
think that that would be something that
I would have noticed of when I first
opened it up but I did not so clearly
oh my god I mean I felt this makes no
sense why would they all be out of order
I don't understand but either way that
means now I get to open to today because
I accidentally opened up ten and one is
still not open oh no how do I put it
together okay all right
[Music]
well now everything that I thought that
I knew was a lie so I guess now I'm 2
days ahead on my advent calendar yeah so
really this is just a quick little vlog
just to say hello and welcome to
December it's kind of crazy because this
entire year has just flown by so quickly
they sat down to edit you guys a video
and I was like this is gonna take me
probably like 4 hours to make this video
as good as I want it to so that's why I
decided to make a quick vlog just to say
hi and a lot of you guys have been
missing my vlogs and I apologize it's
been kind of hard to sort of do
everything that I want to do while also
try to vlog now we're back up here in
the office let's have a quick chat hi so
a lot of stuff is been going on we've
been filming a ton of Christmas videos a
ton of collab videos but now here's the
problem I have to edit all of these
videos I probably have like 15 or 16
videos to edit and it gets super
overwhelming I sat down I was like wow
I'm finally gonna post my Hawaii video
that's gonna be my first vlog of
December and then I looked at my
timeline and I realized I probably had
another 7 to 10 hours of editing to do
on it as a quick preview this is my
current timeline it not only brings us
at about 5 minutes and I feel like
that's why I vlog has a really good
chance it can probably be upwards of
about 40 minutes I might edit out some
things but I recently went on vacation
with my family it was so much fun but
during the vacation is when mario
odyssey came out so instead of blogging
or vlogging and editing while i was on
the trip or even hanging out with my
family which i feel really bad about I
was playing Mario Odyssey god I love
that game look it absolutely is
fantastic so if you guys haven't played
it and if it's on your holiday wish list
great choice so I guess what the moral
of this story was is I thought it would
be easier to film an entire new vlog
instead of going through and trying to
edit and finish this one there was
another video that I planned on posing
for you guys too but then I realized
while that's gonna probably take me at
least four hours so trying to figure out
my time management of what video to post
for you guys today I was like you know
what I just woke up and I'm just gonna
talk to you guys for a hot minute and
here we are you see my new life I've
been showing everyone it's very very
nice my friend Susie got me this
she knows me I need some chapstick is
there any in here SD cards I'm here hair
clips Steve Jobs mini finger Benny
me more hair clips Phillips small I need
chapstick oh yeah that's great
that's alive so in a few videos you guys
are super sneaky because you pick out
the smallest of details things that I'm
like out they won't ever notice a few of
the videos of the pumpkin pie video in
particular and the Sphero unboxing with
a row I posted those after I got the
iPhone 10 but we shot them before I had
the iPhone 10 so you little detectives
you all of the comments I knew this was
gonna happen too but like I was like man
yeah maybe they will notice they think
there's no way that I'm gonna see you
guys see everything it's actually insane
there's another video that I filmed with
RO and as we were filming this I told
her I was like listen I can't have my
phone in this video because I know every
single comment when I post this video is
going to be why are you not using your
iPhone 10 or they plan so far I had
advanced through their videos I was like
man I mean I thought 11 might be out by
the time we post this video I've been
loving the phone so much I feel like I
haven't done an update video and I don't
know like a few weeks which is kind of
crazy I know I know I was planning on
doing a week one with iPhone week 2 with
iPhone week 3 mostly as a joke maybe I
still should do that I'm not sure either
way it's been really great I've had very
very minimal problems and the problems
that I have had are sort of like my own
fault because the one thing that does
drive me crazy it's the middle of the
night I reach over to get my phone and
half of my face is obscured by the
pillow and I try to unlock it it doesn't
unlock and that I'm trying to type in my
passcode so in that instance I
definitely do miss having the home
button and being able to use touch ID
but for the most part I think it's great
I did some really fun videos I very good
drop test with these tack 21 cases that
was so much fun but I was so afraid
because the traps that we were doing
we're gonna be pretty intense and I'd
have to do it over and over again so
they were nice enough to send me a phone
to do the drop test with which I was
very excited about because they sent me
the Space Gray one and I have
silver like oh this is exciting I
started we get to have both phones for
like well over the course of a day when
we film those the only small issue that
I kind of have with the Space Gray is
that it sort of reminds me of the jet
black phone that we had previously I'm
so happy with my decision to go with the
silver I love that it has the stainless
steel around the edge it sort of reminds
me of the first original iPhone so
there's that a little bit of a throwback
the man it's just it really is a great
device another cool thing that I saw
look people there's been a bunch of
renders of the iPhone se too and this
looks really really good like if you
guys want to check this out so that's a
full screen iPhone se my main back
though is the people that are gonna get
the iPhone se I feel like are getting it
because it's cost-effective but to put
in a full LED screen and to put in all
of the features that they're gonna need
to make that work that's gonna raise the
cost significantly so I feel like kind
of defeats the purpose of having that se
phone I'm not sure I don't know this is
an Apple video this is just me having a
chat with my friends you guys being my
friends and I do apologize I'm actually
really really tired today anyway I look
forward to all of the videos that I have
coming out this month so I hope that you
guys will enjoy them I hope that you
will have a holly jolly Christmas I've
been singing that song probably for two
months because I started filming some
Christmas videos I feel like back in
October so at this point for me I think
my Christmas is already it's already
ended well see you guys in my next video
I will definitely be posting one
tomorrow so make sure you come back be
sure to subscribe if you're new and not
subscribed already and of course I have
to tell you to hit the bell because I
don't think subscriptions really work
I'm not sure if notifications are the
way to go if anybody knows how to use
YouTube let me know I would love to know
in the comments below how does YouTube
work I've only been here for about 11 or
12 years and I still am not sure I'll
see you guys later bye happy vlogmas
sort of vid --mess I think that's better
because not every video I'm posting is
going to be a long
[Music]
you